joining me now is congressman eric
swalwell democrat of california and
member of the judiciary committee who is
at the
center of some of these requests
reportedly congressman thanks for coming
back on the show
you found out that the trump doj had
subpoenaed your data
are you allowed to tell us what they got
how much of an invasion of privacy it
was
well it was certainly an invasion of
privacy i still don't know how much
they got you know apple is a little bit
more transparent with its users than
other
providers and so i received an email
from apple it looked like a spam
email that said my uh account
information had been turned over to doj
so we're seeking those answers from doj
right now but the bigger point here meti
is that presidents in our country you
know they set the tone for the country
and so if you have a president who's a
bully a president who has this phony
tough guy persona
that's going to trickle down and so
donald trump
through the years we've seen everyday
americans start to really
treat our health care workers just as
horribly as donald trump would talk
about them
you're seeing nba players having bottles
thrown at them indecency on the
house floor my fear is now that mayors
and governors see that donald trump was
doing this to his
political opponents possibly that maybe
that's what you're going to do now when
you don't like someone who comes to your
city council meeting
and speaks against you you're going to
turn the turn and unleash the local
sheriff
on them that's the real reason here is
that the trickle-down effect
yeah trumpism without trump uh
congressman the investigation is closed
and no
connection was found between your
committee and those alleged leaks
now former trump ag's bill bahr and jeff
sessions have both
denied knowledge of the subpoenas as has
their deputy rod rosenstein
how can that be possible that none of
them knew
uh it's not possible mehdi uh and we
just sent the letter
uh to doj from the house judiciary
committee laying out how we know it's
not possible because
under doj guidelines for members of
congress in a situation like this to
have their data
surveilled the attorney generals the
attorneys general in in this
instance would have to know and i just
don't believe that it was incompetence
and it didn't make its way to them
they know that donald trump routinely
was calling adam schiff
a leaker donald trump routinely was
attacking me on twitter and we happen to
be the only two
on the committee it looks like so far
who were targeted so
yeah i just don't buy it and so i i
guess
um i'm putting the burden on them to
prove to me
that they did not know
i mean the thing is luckily for bar and
sessions they have great reputations for
honesty so
they'll get through this i think uh
congressman on the one hand
it looks a lot like it looks a lot like
the trump justice department may have
crossed some pretty
major lines to try and ferret out
whatever leaks they were searching for
on the other hand i have to point out
that you're a democratic congressman the
obama administration
was also very aggressive in surveilling
journalists from the ap
for example from fox news phone records
etc
uh those journalists among many others
and john brennan
even had to apologize after the cia
surveilled
senate intelligence committee staffers
aren't we kind of
out of lines to cross in this country i
mean obama didn't set
great precedence here i'm sorry to say
many i think that's a good point except
i would distinguish the two and
obama's doj doing that was wrong however
i don't believe there's evidence that
the doj
under president obama was doing it to be
vindictive or that it was politically
motivated it was not a smear and clear
effort
where here we're still learning exactly
what was going on
but it sure smells like a smearing clear
no it's a fair distinction but i think
i'm glad we both agree that it's wrong
whether it's done by a democratic
president or a republican president
we do need to reign in uh surveillance
the surveillance state in this country
and
keep the doj within bounds whether as
you say whether it's barack obama donald
trump or joe biden who's president
and i hope you and your colleagues are
doing that on the committee you created
a flap yesterday congressman when you
revealed that u.s capitol police officer
michael fanon had
apparently been snubbed when trying to
approach
january 6th minimizing congressman
andrew clyde of the gop
have a listen to what fanon said today
i saw him standing outside of an
elevator bay once he got on the elevator
myself and officer dunn accompanied him
on the elevator
and i simply greeted him
extended my hand he stared at me
refused to shake my hand he said that he
didn't know who i was
i introduced myself i said you know my
name is officer michael fanon i'm a d.c
police officer and i fought to defend
the capitol on january 6th
and i explained to him some of the
injuries that i suffered as a result
of that he just stared at me
turned away pulled out his cell phone
looked like he was trying to
record the interaction uh which
ended then we didn't speak and as soon
as the elevator bay doors opened he ran
congressman is it just me or did
democrats get beaten up
and beat themselves up over defund the
police
while republicans are refusing to shake
the hand of capital police
heroes voting to block them from getting
a medal
how is it that your party gets so easily
hammered on police issues and they get
away with that
because we don't punch back hard enough
and i'm punching back is a brother to
two police officers
it's easy to say every other november
that you backed the blue
but when the rubber you know met the
road and
the blue put their lives in front of
ours so that we could flee
and go to a secure location we're really
seeing
who is standing up for the heroes in
this country because right now we're
finding out that to
honor donald trump you have to dishonor
the police
and that's wrong and i hope voters see
that it's been phony for
every election uh before uh now and we
are seeing their true colors and their
true colors are not blue
i have to ask about the lawsuit you
finally serve republican congressman mo
brooks with alleging he helped incite
uh the january 6 riot um congressman
brooks's wife has reportedly sworn out a
warrant for the man who served her at
their home
as far as you know did he do it lawfully
do you think the perp you know for the
purposes of serving the lawsuit
everything was done appropriately by you
and your legal team
yeah my legal team tells me it was done
appropriately medi
but take a step back why was it so hard
to serve
a member of congress why was he ducking
and dodging
service for so long you know he
benefited from the capital being locked
down and visitors weren't able to come
and serve him there but for over a month
and a half he refused to be served
where i come from that's called
consciousness of guilt
well he obviously denies any role in it
even though he is on tape saying some
pretty awful things
uh some pretty things that sound pretty
inciting
um but we'll have to see where your uh
lawsuit goes
uh congressman eric swoll thank you so
much for your time tonight i appreciate
it
hi i'm mehdi hussain thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe
below to stay up to date on the day's
biggest stories
thank you for watching